I've biggest success in. Technology
that this community is achieved.
It's not so much that we've
got wonderful new brilliant.
Energy systems going or anything like
that we've got a few demonstration
projects to prove it's possible.
We've got a big hydroelectric scheme we've
got my flying fox transport the things
you can actually poke a stick at
and say this is radical appropriate
such a soft technology
but if you look at the statistics of the
whole communities lifestyle over the
property what the only way
we really are winning.
As far as the planets concerned is the
fact that we're not using nearly as much.
We've got by with a lot less
servicing and we've found
that it doesn't really matter all
that much. It's enough would have.
In this community decision.
And then. Someone either. Community or.
Things or things. Well it was
always a bit of a nifty project.
There was never enormous
push behind that project.
Was buying more land there's
always been incredible push for.
Cynically i'd say that's
because more dope growing land
but that's not totally true.
It's more the feeling of wishing to
consolidate people wishing for security
and owning this whole valley
was a very important political
and ideological strength
behind this community.
It meant that as a community
we had less neighbours.
We hardly ever conflict out our direct
neighbours with different ideas.
Other communities have great big legal
fights over pesticide spraying that.
Those over the fences and things like
that because we own the
whole valley we don't have
that on a couple of occasions fires of
come over the ridgeline from the neighbor
and we've taken him to court.
And a couple of occasions he's come
a log our logs over the border
and were made a big fuss about it.
So that's about the only interaction we've
had and we've been on very solid ground.
What is happening.
On him and wonderful for its tolerance.
Nimbin is a wonderfully tolerant place.
It's one place like even in that.
What i say that the black spots of
nimbin which is the rainbow cafe
and the freemasons hotel the freemasons
hotel is my favourite hotel anywhere.
It's usually full of appalling
music horrible looking people
and people are blatantly using
drugs and drinking to excess.
But never in my whole 20
years of going frequenting
that place of i've been assaulted.
I've drunk with totally obnoxious looking
bikies with undercover police with some
of the most suspicious looking do you
be as people that you never see.
And yet there is never a
threat to person. This it.
A wonderful cosmopolitan thing in. That
different cultures that respected and.
You feel
that you could just about walk down the
street naked in fact i know someone who did
and no one would take
the slightest notice.
And yet it's also a place where you
know everybody and they know you.
And if you desperate someone might
even lend you five dollars.
You know so funny story.
Idea. I could go on.
Yes.
Funny thing in the story. I
know i guess this doesn't.
I'm sure this is legally ok to say so with
that one of our ideological leaders during
their careers festival who was very keen
on peace love and non-violence
and his child conceived at the
aquarius festivals call softly.
Turned into me the most
beautiful flower child.
He actually.
Assaulted one of my neighbors the still
ruler got dragged into court for it.
And the only thing you could say after
being convicted was i should have hit him
harder.
Where the same fellow unfortunately got
must have irritated some bikies equally
and they probably shot
him in the neck apps
and left his body in the in the
quarry up the top of the hill.
So i sort of had total sympathy.
And i mean. Oh yes. And
most irritating man.
Same time was it was a a oneness
with the environment that
that man showed which is possibly
forgotten. Sometimes moonlight nights.
You just come crashing out of the forest
obviously having walked five kilometres
through the. Totally unknown untracked
bush in the middle of the night
and had to have a wild fire
and his eyes like he was like an animal
out of the forest and i could relate to
that because part of the whole point.
This is a community commune ality of all
the animals live in the forest a love the
fact that all these animals just walk in
and out of my house as if it's part
of the track which was always there.
I just happen to build my house
at the joining of three tracks.
And the animals treat it still as just
exactly what it was a meeting of those three
tracks.
That's very much so. Yes.
I think. Yes.
Well ever since i started taking
mushrooms i was very worried about what
consciousness is what are we who are we.
What's it all for all those
fundamental spiritual questions.
And one of the things i came to us that
there wasn't any reason it just is
and all animals that are are it
sounds semantically tautological
but that's still the way i feel about these
animals that walk around the forest.
They're no more
and no less than i am so being
able to just go by in peace
and have the the go
owners and push turkeys
and all these amazing creatures
just come and look at me
when i'm sitting there watching television
to me is that an amazing event.
Because i think women. When.
You know. I don't take it that far. I
don't think there's anything wrong.
Squashing much flies fact i find it quite
amusing you squash them then you watch
the lizards eat them.
The part of the cycle.
So i'm not a buddhist in that sense.
I've never formalized what
religious views i've had.
Except that i don't believe in any
of them and none of it makes sense
but i'm quite prepared to
leave it not making sense.
Are strong. Yes of course everyone
must mention the difference.
Most people tend to be buddhist in the
sense of valuing all life thinking that
that the mountains the trees
everything has spirit which it does.
When the most beautiful spiritual times
he was walking around the valley by
moonlight you feel like you're
you've come back to a primeval world
beyond beforetime and it's the middle
of the day and you wearing sunglasses.
That's the closest way i can express what
it's like to walk around this valley by
moonlight. It's so quiet.
You can hear a car for five kilometres
away easily you can even tell which car it
is now that's under its imponderable
when you live in somewhere like sydney.
Where you might hear a
siren three streets away
and that's about it.
Yes this valley is acoustically one
unit. And you smell things here.
It's got wonderful smell. It's got.
Beautiful sounds everyone mentions at night
time walking around here can hear all
of the birds the different sorts of owls
night jars the you can hear things going
on and wallabies hopping around.
It's like it's a whole world happening that
just there aren't people dominating it.
We just one more night
animal walking around.
I think. Important.
Are music was almost a driving
force in this culture.
This aquarian culture we had the
protest movement we had bob dylan.
Joan baez all of those people and
they really created the dream.
I mentioned before broke celtic infusion
rock. But it's also the ballad.
You get people. Joan baez
thing the thing about.
Like the circle song as one of the
classic it's about the circle of life.
And one of the key lines
about the boy. If cut will.
Change the car wheels through the
town and then the next person.
And his dreams of lost their
grandeur coming through.
I see a lot of the people around me feeling
a little bit sort of jaded about the
tunnel experience and it sometimes
feels a bit like a holiday camp
or so much like a beach place
where people go to retire and die
but i think partly it's because
the dreams that come true.
They've lost their grandeur
and it's all sort of worn off a bit
because sometimes it's not the reality of
what's happened but the way
that people feel about it which affects
the way they talk about it so.
I feel at the same inspirational creating
a new vision thing which has been.
Like the led zeppelin song. Stairway
to heaven. That was one of the.
The hymns of our movement
and everyone can play
that song on the guitar
but it's just one of the sort of
rites of passage in this community.
And the the forest will
echo with laughter.
If one of the most amazing lines
in the middle of that song
and funny because it brings together the
two elements of this culture which i've
always found contradictory ones
that the forest echoing the laughter the
silence on the other hand the incredible
noise with which most people play music
around here right from beginning bobby
craven scalp sales down there which was the
nearest point to sell atrocity we could
plug in a thousand what amplifier
was booming and shaking
and shocking the whole valley with
really quite miserable doors type rock
and roll and all the concerts around here.
I couldn't relate to culture at all
until i learned to wear earplugs
and now before i go into any constant
round here i plug up my years with toilet
paper and you simply have to
try the few reasons i think
that i've got still my hearing. Was
many people around here are quite deaf.
It's one of the. My theories about the
communication between people and.
Extremely simple.
People don't communicate because half the
people are too stoned to talk coherently
in the other half to death to hear.
And you know i think that the communications
the lifeblood of any community
and we're not doing enough.
Well that's work to our
favor. We've collected. Yes.
The burden of being seen
as a visionary center.
As wonderful for example
my immediate neighborhood.
There's now a totally rip up you lated
on the only person who was there in the
original hamlet. Although people
have come a germans except one.
Tony was not electrician from up in queensland.
But all of the others are germans.
Germans know more about
nimbin than australians do.
It's considered a mecca for anti-authoritarian
forces when they call themselves.
Junkies or anarchists or what
a doesn't really matter.
The point is they're anti-the state and.
They've been over inspected over defected
over everything in germany by an
excessively efficient public service.
They come here to escape it as he opposite
point of the globe as the opposite end
culturally and for that reason we've got
all these wonderful immigrant germans.
Who are skilled. Ambitious.
Old enough and have the
wherewithal to be constructive
and my whole neighborhood has been totally
rebuilt in a wonderful way by the
ingress of all is wonderful germans.
So it's attracted a lot of negative
attention from government bureaucracies.
For example if i win i get regularly stopped
because i drive an old car they were
slick my license. And the fact
that the license has the wrong
gender doesn't seem to bother them.
What bothers them is that as the word
tangible falls they promptly get out
and start searching the car for marijuana.
The image of the place has got a lot
of attention unwanted for both police
and drug traffickers in general
it was beautifully ambiguous
but yes it's it's been also a wonderful
drawcard we've got an unbelievable string
of talented wonderful people
come to this property.
Most of whom we've used
poorly and consumed
and spat out my biggest guilt about this
community is how poorly we've served many
of the very talented ideal it ideologically
motivated people because what's
happened this community is built
of the cream and the dregs.
They both come together where unselective
and often i'm not quite sure.
Sometimes which category
to put people in is not
that i'm being touched mental
it's just simply the fact
that people come here sometimes
for their own purposes
and sometimes the community purposes just
occasionally enlightened self-interest
makes them serve both masters.
Ok. Riot.
My name is sally spain and i came to
nimbin. In 1976 one hundred seventy six.
And i've lived here on
and off since then on
and off because some of the
time i go over the border.
The aborigines used to call this
country the country of the men
and they sent of the ceremonies.
On mount warning
and the terrain here is rougher than where
i grew up which is just over the border
in south east queensland which
catwalk at once told me.
Was with stradbroke island and and mount
turnberry in the country of the women
and i find that the values
that are expressed in both of these
places one on each side of the ball.
Yeah part and parcel of the same thing.
I don't know how many people would agree
with me because a lot of the people who
came to nimbin
and some of them with the very best
of our generation came from sydney
and in those days we had because of the
hard work of our parents generation a lot
of freedom to discuss and talk about
the ideas and out of the universities
and the colleges and the
workplaces there came a feeling
that it would be good in in
view of some of the crises
that seem to be be setting the world
to set up an ideal society and young
and naive as we were i think we
expected to walk out of the country
and set one up just like that
of course 20 years later
when people talk about it that's
fine. Yeah i'm sorry. Yeah sure.
Of course 20 years later
when people talk about it.
They see the vision
and they also see some of the disappointments
as well as some of the things
that have been achieved. I
think in our generation
and the generations later on haven't had
such total freedom because of the economic
times that came upon us.
We had an opportunity to
express some of the things
that we believed in which was like
a whole lifestyle with with trust
and friendship with people and
some connection to the earth again
and a rural community fresh air
and freedom to bring up our children
perhaps in a way outside of the city areas
and so on
and i think in a lot of cases some of
this has been achieved in other cases it
hasn't because people have got sidetracked
drugs were a problem with our generation
and there were other issues too.
But nimbin
and in a way has been a learning centre
many more people than are actually here now
have passed by
and some of them have learnt difficult
lessons here because it wasn't easy to come
from at least a semi urban lifestyle and
suddenly plant oneself in a rural area
but some of the people who have
come here have found friendship.
I think from some of them
found disappointment also.
Because of course the vision couldn't
always be immediately realized
or even ever realized
perhaps but it doesn't mean
that a lot of the people here
haven't held on to the principles
that they espoused when they
when they dropped out of
that was what it was called in those days.
That's all i can think of right now.
The insular. Community.
You know i think probably we did some partly
that's contributed to by the terrain i
mean in a sense. We're doing both
things because we live in queensland
and my husband works
and we've got our children now at school
so i taught them in the early years. But.
To a degree. We've got
we've got rough terrain
and to walk across to our
neighbours there is something
that you can't really do because you've
got to sort of hack your way through
or go right round via a long way
and i think just dealing with.
Planting orchards and building houses and
looking after children it might mean
that people don't associate but
in other ways i think they do
when i was here more full time. And
the little school was down there.
The children would visit the kindergarten.
And i would go down and be part
of the committee of the school
and i think through group endeavors.
People get a lot of their social life
where they might hop skip across to a
neighbour because of the
actual nature of the terrain.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
Down. Sure i think that's right.
And that's what we were talking about before
i think if you have a community where
it's group life then you make some
sacrifices to be part of the group
and sometimes that's that's individually
an individuality and sometimes.
That means that you have to
be able to group pressures
and sometimes the group is wrong.
So there's always that danger.
I mean sometimes it's correct you get
some energy from people being different
and you're free to be different.
Amongst them and who express
what you felt you should express
but on the other hand there is there is
tyranny by the group and i think the.
What can happen to. And that's
something that that would bother me.
I think in a way because i tend to
relate to people on an individual level.
So i found beautiful friends here.
But but i avoid the tribal
meetings because it bothers me
that some decision can be made and perhaps
that's an unjust decision not always
but it can. Been.
A reflection.
I mean just you know reflection.
You know i think there are things
there are there are great lessons
that can be learnt from
what's happened here.
But there's also with every step forward.
Sometimes i think there's a step backwards
i mean people here are more conscious of
a healthy lifestyle and they are more
conscious of having organic food
but because they they
landed in a rain for us.
Sometimes hygiene
and sanitation was slack whereas if you
if you went up to the coast where the
council had more control in the hinterland
there. So notation was all right.
But people might not realize so much about
that their alternative ways of dealing
with health problems and things like
that it was it was always very dualistic.
That's what i found i mean if i breastfed
the children here publicly to a late age
that was never a problem. If i did it
up there you know over the border.
That was more conspicuous.
But if i fed the children sweets down here
which i think is perfectly correct then
that might be a cause of some
neighbourly interference.
If i fed them sweets up
there. That was no problem.
It was like that always i
always had that experience.
If i birth the children at home.
Up there which i did because
our house wasn't finished here
and my mother was up there
she was a midwife then
that wasn't a problem here
people so the home birth is fine
and in those days i had i had no feeling
of going there a hospital i had three
healthy children. But.
But if i if i was home birthing
up there people would would say.
Good heavens how unguarded of you.
So i always had this experience of
living between but not so much.
Now i think that some of the ideas
that were that were current and
that were good ideas that came
here have spread widely so that
when i say to my cousins.
Look you don't have to come up here to
see if you've been being true to the
traditions the australian traditions
of of looking after your children
and having basic morality and giving them.
You know a healthy lifestyle and keeping
them in touch with nature then that
when i different to them. I
mean it's not so different now.
So much.
Whereas i don't know i draw a lot of
strength from beautiful people who are here.
You know that have come i mean i've
met some extraordinary souls here.
Who came you know with.
Most beautiful ideas and
managed to manifest them but
but also i mean we had people who were
travelling through who were who are you know
out of it.
Who had had had too many drugs who are
difficult to deal with we've had both very
extreme. And they've been more
free to express themselves here
and i would have in other places
but i don't draw so much from the
group life as a whole that i did
when the children were
going to the kindergartens
when it was very much a group
parent sort of endeavor.
But i do draw from from the people who
felt to come here some friendships.
So i guess that's the way out
but that's just i think that's to
do with my personality too i'm.
I don't know i wouldn't have life didn't
like school or large groups very much.
Anyway in the first place so it
seems odd to have come to a commune
but there are.
Extreme.
I think it can be.
Yes i've seen good people who've had
good ideas and have been harassed
and criticized for them and who've left
and i've seen good strong people who've
managed to put their point of view on have
stayed. I think because we
were such a loud generation.
Everybody had their opinions and
some of them were very good but that
that cause people conflict i
think that that's sort of thing
and also also i've seen
incredible wisdom in people
and managing to deal with other people
and to to draw on experiences to to
know themselves more and to mature.
I've seen both really i've seen
people who are deluded and still are.
And i've seen people
who've who've realised.
Well what it comes down
to an end which is that
that their god consciousness if you like
the fact that god created the planet
and that they've said they're here to
care for it and to care for other people.
I've seen people reach that that stage
and i've seen people miss it
completely both actually.
Right. Which is.
You know but it probably did me
good. I certainly was challenged.
I mean we had thousands of people.
It seemed like coming through here before
the house was built the early days were
pretty hectic i had little
children and all the things
that other people dealt with no
water and things like that at first
that kind of stuff
but i had it easier than some because i
did go across the board across the border
so that they were
co-parenting by my mother
and david had work to do sometimes up
there so we were coming back and forth.
Some people had it harder than
that. You know that's true.
But on the other hand i think some
people i hopefully i feel at that
that they drew drew support from the
group in their hard times more would you
reckon that's right. Yeah well you get
both. That's right. Yeah and it's tricky.
It's painful when you get somebody
good sizing i mean i married david
and came here and i didn't agree with
that rule that there should be no dogs.
I can.
Understand people's logic behind it
because there are lots of paddy melons
and stuff like that
but i never would have come to a
community where there weren't dogs.
So when i tried to bring dogs in
and just followed my feelings on
that because i really think that that
people and animals should be close.
I think that's why christ was born
in a stable to show that the animals
and people are meant to be close
and we had the sort of dogs
that didn't chase paddy melons but i
got into a lot of conflict there and
that was hurtful but it is i suppose
that happens in any walk of life
and to a degree. You know although perhaps
we were more overt about it here.
I don't know perhaps that's oh yeah.
You know. And you know that's right.
And this is that's what
david says my husband.
This is the the biggest land cooperative
where people have come together
and that's one of these donnish
only good things about it
that you said once the fact that
people with a tiny bit of capital
and we were lucky because from
david's father we had more capital
and other people to set up fruit
trees and to help build a house
but for people with small amount of
capital they can get access to land
and the land has always been locked
in australia from earliest times
and so that's that that was very
important that was revolutionary
and that's something that should
be observed on the other hand
that had probably problems too because
we where we are here were insulated by a
creek and it and the forest at the back
but some people who might have had such a
strong personality might have got pushed
more into a corner in earlier times
and not been allowed to have so much
land as somebody else who was because it
wasn't all set up with
rules and regulations.
I think since going to land cooperatives
made it more fair by trying to make it
spelt out at the beginning. Who
could be where and what they had.
No. Right.
Yeah. Because it. I haven't seen it.
Is that right. What you're talking
about there is anarchy isn't it.
And that that's the
spirit. That's in heaven.
I mean if everybody who had come
here had had that heavenly vision
or had managed to hang onto it.
Then you wouldn't have ever had
any problem and a lot of them did
but also it was very quickly earth with
with a lot of disputes which i guess work
had to happen in the physical
reality but but that
that heavenly vision i
don't have any doubt
that people had had it's
really strange but i follow.
I follow the strategy and
and our generation was a leo generation
that's why they were such argumentative
talkers. But they also had their
leo was in pisces which is
that which is the sign of the person
who's at their old stage of life
and has a heavenly vision as well as an
earthly vision that's while people sit
and dream there and heaven away. And so
we got our heavenly vision at that age.
Some people get it at a different age and.
Everybody has their chance i think
to do to envision something of that
that christ like thing on the earth
and i think people did have that
but of course you know the
earth is not perfect.
So some of the things that
were done were perfect
and some of them weren't that's about it
that keeps coming under the same point.
Right.
Yes i think that's probably too i
meant true if we had a fine education
and i know we had a lot of
skills from that but i know
that also we had more than a lot of other
generations experience of classrooms to a
very late age especially the
ones who were not deterred.
Three institutions and i know
that the early days and then
and were partly a childhood
that was played out.
I mean there was a lot of fun people
people didn't have no clothes
and they did walk all over the place
and dance and sing i mean there was
that crazy sort of summer of of of.
Just an innocence in a way i mean that
that brought its problems to but.
But in a way that that was a childhood
that some people had never had
that they dropped out to to enjoy and and
as always happens that their people.
If they don't go through a
certain stage of got to do it.
Later and a lot of people
had a freedom then.
That was
that was very beautiful it was it was a
celebration there were some very good
things. That. The people
enjoyed in terms of.
Just just being free for a while.
As well. People are no longer young.
I guess and it's not appropriate.
I don't think to try and
call that that back.
That was a special time i mean there are
echoes of it all around but i think that.
That was a time that was given
and then you're supposed to get
the messages from your time
and realize the things that you dreamt of
so i don't think that that's appropriate.
Now but it was appropriate.
Then it was a very special freedom and
they were very special friendships.
And
and of course many previous generations
had been too tightly control
and sexual morality comes into that.